- [Narrator] Okay, just watch.
Three, two, one.
(horn blowing)
This is Thailand's Maeklong Market.
(brakes squealing)
About an hour south of Bangkok,
every day beginning at
6:20 in the morning,
a train runs through
Maeklong Railway Market,
one of the largest produce and
seafood markets in Thailand,
through the stalls selling
fruit, ice cream, fish,
through everything.
And if you're wondering which came first,
the market or the train,
the answer is the market.
The Maeklong Railway built
a commuter train to Bangkok
back in 1905.
The track they laid ran
right through the middle
of this market, which had
been around for decades.
Rather than moving,
the vendors stayed put,
adjusting their business
to the train times,
eight times a day, seven days a week.
(speaking Thai)
- [Narrator] This system has
been perfected over the years.
With produce just inches
from the train's wheels,
tourists and vendors wait
as the train passes through.
Then, everything goes back to normal,
or at least as normal as an
active train line market can be.